that's all but I'm dying up here this is
about the Comedy Store in the 70s all
the comedian's that work there of course
you've worked as a committee for many
years starting out must been got to be
kind of tough in the seventies desperate
times because you had comedian Richard
Pryor you had a comedian standing right
next to Richard Pryor very funny person
that couldn't afford a sandwich right so
as you start out in comedy it's really
nothing has changed because it's tough
when no one knows who you are and you're
traveling all over the country yeah
horrible things happen like what I've
been chased I've been chased and chased
yeah I've made people you made people
angry we have a comedy yeah sometimes I
do okay I saw like what's just like for
example give me an example of something
were saying it was south fast ten
seconds in to a set in Orlando I walk
out and I said put your hands together
for the other comedians ladies and
gentlemen put your hands together and
then I noticed a lady not putting our
hands together right now go what's the
matter lady didn't like the other comics
and she goes no it's not that I didn't
like the other comics it's just that
holds up no hand just can't let her go
because she has a stump hand
yeah and you have called her out in
front of everybody and the entire
audience Minh
I know the sound this audience recreated
it beautifully what so what do you how
do you get out of that that's called
digging a hole in comedy I acknowledge
the fact that I've dug a horrible hole
and just spent the rest of the 45
minutes to an hour talking about how
horrible yeah I am yeah she ended up it
ended up being a great show
okay acknowledge but I've had women
vomit I've had a hair I had one woman
vomit in Coconut Grove where no one
helped her at all no one came so she
threw up and no one came to help out her
friends the staff she just sat there the
entire time and then during that same
show a woman's hair cut on fire and
again nothing happened no one did
anything
no one shut the show down or there no
one saying can we get you can we help
you ma'am what do you got going on
nothing
and I was just on stage going what is
happening why is no one helping these
women yeah so yeah it's it goes really
bad when people know who you are when
you're Conan and you go on tour and
everyone comes out it's great but when
you're a comics starting out and people
are like 20% of the people are there to
see you it's just goes bad a lot of the
time yeah bachelorette parties fighting
wait there was was it really one where
there was a bachelorettes fighting one
bachelorette party is horrible two rival
bachelorette parties and you're there to
perform yeah and I'm up on stage going
ladies please yeah and then I had this
horrible thing happened to where I
acknowledge a fist fight broke out a
woman tried to come up on stage this is
all the same show woman tried to come up
on stage with me and get my drink and
then it's the la jolla Comedy Store so
it's like 80 pound weaklings the
bouncers are comedians so these two
little kids come up and so then as this
woman's walking out the Bachelorette is
getting dragged out Irie cap and I go
what a perfect way for this to end and I
go the drunk Bachelorette getting
carried out and she goes can I say
something
oh I said sure why not she goes I'm not
drunk I am Sarab oh yeah what do you do
then just give up acting Conan that all
these stories are about women yeah like
do ever do man never cause problems at
your shows are you just bring something
out in women no well I mean women are
not the best comedy club audience
members I'm gonna say that right now
why is that because they really don't
want to be there yeah there's something
to do they got dragged there you say by
a guy they're victims they've been taken
yeah by other people if you're a
bachelorette party please don't go to a
comedy club go see some guy take his
pants off I've been a problem for many
years you know I like that this ended
with a very good public service
you